can be Petty for a second
sorry I'm gonna do it anyway so I used
to have a series on here called nitpick
Rants and I haven't done it for a while
and I think a shorts format might be a
good way to bring it back because
something that I failed to notice while
watching the new trailer for The Little
Mermaid which I did a reaction to in the
break room of Geeks was that in the shot
where Ursula reaches her tentacles out
for Ariel she has eight of them
this strikes me as odd because in the
original she had six now some people
will cite that as like oh they made a
mistake um that was never a mistake
because she had six tentacles and two
arms she had eight limbs she was an
octopus now she's got eight tentacles
and two arms for a total of 10 limbs
so is she not an octopus anymore I mean
maybe in theory she she could be a squid
but that's all backwards because her
tentacles are clearly longer than her
arms and a squid has six shorter arms
and two long tentacles so that doesn't
even work they fixed a problem that
wasn't a problem and made it worse